you know it's really i got really angry
today so my main segment was um
uh i was talking about my main channel
pro-life democrats took out a full-page
ad in the new york times
saying the democrats have gone crazy on
abortion and that if they don't moderate
their position
they're going to lose 30 of their voter
base to donald trump
because like i i talked to stephen
crowder about this on his show
conservative pro-life and i was like i'm
pro-choice but these people are nuts
and crowder basically said the
republicans are offering up negotiations
to disaffected liberals like let's have
a conversation about it the left is
saying
no like outright and so anyway anyway i
bring this up because
we ended up seeing this and there was
another story uh on article
written by bridget fedesy you're do you
you guys know bridget yeah
commentator she's she's great and she
talked about how she got hundreds of
emails from people who are politically
homeless
some of them are conservatives who are
gonna vote for biden but she said for
the most part it seems like
she wouldn't be surprised if trump wins
in a landslide based on the things she
was hearing
i was talking about this i started to
get more and more heated because
the the so the other the other the other
house is in philly
uh the other like where the where the
studio is actually functioning and we're
trying to build this one out
and uh i i thought we were safe i
thought it was totally fine i lived in
new york
and i remember the protests were getting
a little crazy and i was like this is
years ago
so i'd see him periodically and i'd be
like whatever they're just marching
around it's no big deal but if civil
unrest gets bad i don't want to be here
then some bombs got planted i have no
idea what that was about i don't think
it was about
uh like political or anything like that
and politics
but i had moved from new york to jersey
partly because two cops got executed in
front of my house
uh i look out my window i look down the
street
not this intersection right here but the
next one over so it was literally just
like one block over
two gops two cops are sitting in their
car and a guy came up and said
he posts on instagram you take two of
ours we take two of yours killed these
two guys and so i realized like
there's some there's some political
problems coming so i moved to the
suburbs eventually i'm like in jersey
i was in jersey that's when the bombs
happened and i was like i can't live
here this is getting too crazy for me
and like my thing is i traveled all
around the world covering all of this
conflict in crisis
so i don't want it anywhere near where i
live because i see what that stuff is
like
so it started getting worse i'm like i'm
leaving i moved to the
to the philly suburbs outside like not
even that close to fellas on this side
of the road it's in jersey
and i was like we are safe here there
are but trees surrounding us
we have very few neighbors everybody
smiles and waves the cops are right over
there and they smile how's it going
hey good to see you officer friendly and
the riots started and then we heard the
helicopters
and i'm sitting in my in the other
studio and it's like
crazy sirens everywhere helicopters i go
outside in the deck and i look i'm like
they're within a few miles of my house
this is ridiculous
so you know i did i bought a bunch of
guns and i had said in january i'm never
buying guns never want to go to my house
no guns
no guns we called the police the police
couldn't respond to these people
they couldn't respond to you so i went
out and bought weapons
i heard your story where the 911's like
we can't do anything you're on your own
you had a gun and i'm like man i better
do something about this
then joe biden tweets out we're going to
ban weapons of war we're going to come
for assault weapons and i'm like oh come
on
yeah the police now you defund the
police you support these people
and then i say okay fine i'll take care
of myself i'm gonna go buy weapons i'm
gonna keep my
my house safe my friends safe and then
you two you're gonna take my guns away
now
these people are their minds they're
arresting people defending themselves
the mccloskey's the guy
in milwaukee this poor man in in omaha
who's his business was being attacked
and they not they decked his
seven-year-old dad and he warned them
back up don't do it and they attack him
anyway and they indict
him so now we're in the middle of
nowhere yep
now now there's the best part if you
come within
if you come anywhere near my house
you're on my property
yeah in a castle doctrines the same i'm
like
i mean i'm really out there and the
closest
i mean my mailbox is a mile away from my
house i'm not kidding
an actual mile from my house so
i mean if anyone comes anywhere near me
i i even thought about putting land
mines in
on my home you can't legally do that can
you i'm
i do like the squirrels but the deer
might trigger the deer you know yeah
you know what they do in uh i think i
could be wrong with the country i think
it's in
um cambodia because they have all of the
land mines from the kama rouge i think
it's i think it's cambodia they just
sent goats out oh
man and then the goats like i want to
get goats so somebody invented this
thing it's like a big
ball with a bunch of like sp like mops
like stick sticking out of it and plates
and it just rolls around deadening land
detonating land mines but anyway
the the general ideas my understanding
is that new jersey is
semi-castle doctrine you can defend
yourself only if you have no choice
like you have to retreat first but if
you're cornered
you can defend yourself with appropriate
force and so i'm like
so if someone breaks into my house right
these are the questions i have someone
breaks in my house
and there's the back door right behind
me but my friends are upstairs
do i just say bye everybody you're on
your own i'm the one with the gun but
i'm gone cause i'm not going to prison
for you
or do i go upstairs not retreating
confronting the person breaking because
i'm worried
they're going to hurt my friends and
family you really don't
even think about the laws when it's
happening exactly at least i didn't
i mean i i propped myself behind a wall
where i could see
three of the you you know how my living
room was set up i brought myself behind
that wall
where the bathroom was and i could see
three of the windows and it was the ones
that they were hitting
it sounded like they were hitting it
with sticks um and i was like man the
second they come through
does dc stand your ground or castle
doctrine um i think it's duty to retreat
i didn't even look
into it i was just like i'm gonna have
to deal with this
you know what you don't have time to
think about it you know you know why any
state that says you have a duty to
retreat is wrong
because you're in your house it's true
where do you retreat too yeah like where
am i supposed to go
under my bed what do you guys want me
i'll retreat outside and then be in the
woods and then die of exposure or what
give them my house then i have no food
no shelter no access to resources
i understand the general idea but
there's so much wrong with with this
concept
of you have to retreat because here's
the other issue let's say
you're in your house and they say if
someone is going to break in you have to
retreat
so they're banging on your windows and
you're like i better retreat you want
the back door and there's a guy waiting
for the baseball
that was my problem there there they
were shooting fireworks at three of the
four
sides of my house and then the other
side was an alleyway and that was where
they were like
banging so it sounded like there was
just people surrounding my house i
thought
i mean there could have been hundreds of
people for all i knew like i had no idea
because it was like blinding light in
every window
and so i was like i could flee out the
basement door
on the side but there's stuff flying at
those windows so clearly that's not safe
and i was on a corner um
it was it it was bizarre when your house
when you're surrounded and you you're in
a duty retreat
what's the legal implication there if
you
i mean if you retreat into your bedroom
and then they come into your house
and you open fire and you have you
legally retreated no you didn't treat
but to where i i have no idea
but you didn't retreat into the into the
arms outdoors escape escape run away
yeah but when there's a mob how do you
do that
yep and then you'll get you'll get
treated like the omaha guy i mean it
could have been one person for all or
well it probably it was at least two
people or three people but
i mean it could have been one person it
could have been 100 people i had no idea
it was just loud
and bright my house was pitch black and
it was so bright it looked like it was
noon
um because just from the fireworks and
what do you do
where are you where do you go i told my
daughter lay on her bedroom floor
because at least her bedroom was
up on the hill so it was not on ground
level i don't not only that
it's not just about retreating but like
what about your kid yeah is she going to
be able to run as fast as you
is she going to be able to climb the
same fences as you or
you know yeah uh if it was someone like
me
and i would and i guess i i i would
imagine that there's some leeway
if you're acting in defense of others
but you don't
know how the courts are going to treat
you so i understand there's probably a
lot of people correcting me because look
i'm a new
gun owner i haven't researched a lot of
these laws recently reached out to a
criminal uh lawyer about
like what i need to do to be legal
moving you know and stuff like that
and i'm sure they're gonna say oh here's
what happens if someone breaks in and
this state and all stuff i get it
but what we're seeing right now is
morality policing yeah it doesn't matter
if you're justified it doesn't matter if
you're right
we got the guy in omaha literally saying
don't do it in backing away
and they still indicted him and one of
the indictments was quite literally him
warning them not to attack him
they were like well that was a threat
that was a terroristic threat saying
what back up don't do it yeah
so even if even if you did the right
thing you're talking about
duty to retreat doesn't matter doesn't
matter you could run full speed away
from your house
yelling help and they'll say oh but they
were they were they were trying to
incite a riot by yelling help to get
everyone to come out and start
attacking oh and those make it up
they'll make it up to say these poor
peaceful protesters it sounds like
you've lost faith in the
system i mean that's on purpose or
you're losing yeah i think it's
intentional i think they're trying to
i bought guns because i have no faith in
the system because i need to make sure
i'm safe and you're safe and everyone
here is safe
so now the added advantage of being in
the middle of nowhere is one of the
concerns i have watching that
video from milwaukee they were standing
in the street
and so they can argue i'm not on your
property i'm on public property while
harassing you and maybe even throwing
things at your house
where where i am now you come anywhere
near my house you're on my property you
go in the woods you're on my prize a big
property in the middle of nowhere i
can't put the costs down but the general
idea is
i want to make sure that anybody who
eventually finds their way somehow
i don't know no matter what you do
you're on my property i'll tell you what
we're gonna have in-ground auto defense
turrets go
yeah we were talking about setting up
tests i'm kidding we're not getting a
volunteer
a friend of uh a friend of mine who's
also
right-wing and a little bit
controversial when they they
live in a similar area to me about an
hour away same state though
when they moved in they were like so
what's the law here about if people show
up at your house
and the sheriff was just like if they
are if they're on your property you
shoot them
and i was like i'm gonna move there yeah
that's here where you're at now
yeah i like it yeah there are a lot of
states like that
uh missouri for instance so the
mccloskeys
you know you know that's terror that's
so sad man that their got that they got
charged when they were just brandishing
a weapon to
scare the people off they were on
private property they came on
pointed out and they pointed at that on
their cheap jobs she pointed at him and
like walked towards him
so so the issue for me is with all these
stories is that oh
i always tell people that they're always
going to find an excuse
because everything moves in increments
right
we're not going to see in my opinion or
we might
like a bunch of black lives matter
people right now running up to a random
elderly one's home beating the crap out
of on a live stream and burning her
house down that's really extreme
and everyone would turn on them but it
slowly happens right
and they have excuses so first they go
to mccloskey's house
the mccloskeys are eating dinner they
see this mob come in the gate gets
broken somehow
and so they pop their weapons and say
back off then the black ops matter group
says we were peacefully protesting and
they pulled guns
then these leftists go oh and the media
will never show you the broken gates
or any of that any of the things that
they destroyed on their way there for
that peaceful protest so so
it's the increment though right as long
as the regular liberals can go
yeah but i mean even though they were
trespassing don't you get a little
extreme we pull out an assault rifle
then what happens next then we get the
milwaukee guy now they're standing from
his house screaming for hours and hours
and he branches his weapon and he gets
arrested straight up
and then they say oh wow i can't believe
he was pointing the gun at those
peaceful protesters
the next thing that's gonna happen is
like they're gonna go to someone's house
and they're gonna kick the door in
and they're going to be like dude he
kicked the door but he didn't deserve to
die yeah
if right now somebody kicked the door
into like a random person's house
the meat like the media might have no
choice so like the andy no incident
do you you know andy no yeah he got
brutally beaten in the street by
anti-fog yeah
the media had no choice it was such a
dramatic escalation
from what antifa had done in the past
that everyone was like whoa whoa whoa
too much too fast
so antibiotic pull back a little bit
pull back oops oops
and then every time they started working
in all the hit pieces the smears calling
him a white supremacist
now that he's a white supremacist now
the media won't cover it
if he gets attacked again so it's
increments
i talked about this a long time ago and
i've been predicting they're gonna start
coming to people's homes
and then they started coming to people's
homes i predicted the morality police
will arrest
you when you defend your property
several months ago i was like it's only
a matter of time before they go to
someone's house
some guy's like stay off my property and
the cops are like it's easier to arrest
the homeowner
than it is to deal with the mob and that
happened already and now
omaha is probably the mo the most
worrying and terrifying story yet jake
gardner
marine veteran with two tours in iraq i
think
yeah bar owner small business owner
minding his own business giving warnings
backing away
and they came for everything in his
business his family his home
he was so much nicer than me or like
half the people i know i mean did you
watch the video of him talking about the
woman's smartly nice guy
like i was like wow i should be nice
like that and then i was like wait no i
shouldn't he's dead right now because of
these people
um i'm wondering but he was just so
good like and they still made him into a
demon
yeah like i this is where they busted
into the bar
this group they started smashing stuff
up what happened they walked into the
bar
so there was like a group smashing up
windows in omaha and
the bar owner's dad came out and told
them like some pr something the effect
of like probably back off you can push
somebody you push somebody okay
and then someone runs up full speed and
just like drop kicks him or something
and slams him to the ground
and he's like 70. disproportionate but i
look the dad should not have shoved
somebody right okay
but it doesn't warrant jumping and
decking the guy somebody shoves you you
got to know when you're like
okay back off man but uh but it's it's
true you know
criticism where it's due although it's
not the most egregious thing that
happened that night
so the sun came over like yo what are
you doing don't don't mess with my dad
and two guys start encroaching on him he
pulls up his shirt to
show his weapon and you can it's all on
video and he's like don't do it i'm
warning you don't do it don't do it he's
backing away
the two guys attack him he pulls out his
gun and while they're holding him down
he fires two warning shots
they run away as he's struggling to get
up it's like on the ground and he's like
staggered
this guy james skurlock jumps on his
back puts him in a choke hold and then
he
yells it was like 18 seconds where he
was choking him he switches the gun to
his left
puts it over his shoulder and fires then
they took everything from him
the the the law the law came in so first
they said it was clear-cut self-defense
the d.a said clear-cut self-defense we
got it on video the dude was on the
ground and he got attacked
the landlord for his bar get out the
landlord for his home apparently i'm
learning from cassandra
yeah i could be wrong but i'm pretty
certain that's what i was reading today
because i i remember being like wait
what that's probably why i was on the
west coast yeah
so then he loses everything his job his
income his business
and then finally the last thing he had
freedom
the black lives matter groups went to
the went to the city protested rioted
you know whatever
i shouldn't say right because i don't
know exactly what they did but the
community pressure
resulted in the da saying okay special
prosecutor and then the grand jury
argued that because he warned them he
was threatening them and because he was
threatening them had a gun it was a
felony
and then he got a man so it's like
imagine telling someone
stay away from me i have a gun and they
say oh terroristic threats you're under
arrest
so now you can't warn somebody which
means if you do shoot what
supposed to do um bang shoot them no
warning don't say anything because if
you say something they're going to
charge you for it
yeah they stripped everything from this
guy
and he will not be the last did he kill
himself
yes yeah or or so he they found him dead
with the people
yeah he sent he sent goodbye texts to a
lot of people wow
38 marine marine veteran i believe was
38 38 two tours in iraq
and he was a small business owner marine
veteran regular guy
he volunteered with the trump campaign
but he was libertarian
leaning and he was he was the video of
him that's gone viral is him saying like
the women's march is it's great that
they're expressing themselves their
criticisms of trump are warranted that's
how they feel they have a right to
express themselves i'm happy they're not
violent
super chill dude super chill and they
started accusing me of being a racist
they started making up lies saying he
was posting racist things on facebook
i i tried to find it i do my research i
couldn't find anything
did you see so there's a medium article
that was viral
and it's kind of what kicked stuff
kicked all this off there was this
activist
from omaha and he wrote this like long
unhinged
blog i mean it was a conspiracy theory
to end all conspiracy theories
but he he was picking apart like the
logos of the bars
and one of them was called um
i'm blanking on it i've had a very long
day and i'm on very little sleep
but it had a key in the logo like
old-fashioned key
yeah and in the the handle part it was
like a plus sign
you know like a cut out in an
old-fashioned key and they said
the plus sign was meant to represent the
swastika
and they put i am not even kidding i've
posted screenshots of this on my twitter
i
i didn't want to link to the article
itself because it was
i mean the left gets really unhinged
with their conspiracy theories like
they make the whole frogs returning gay
thing look really really really moderate
really moderate yeah alex jones moderate
i mean it makes more sense than anything
that they're saying
but this it was i'm sorry to be fair to
alex jones he was referencing a study on
actually no i know
i know but everybody was making them
hermaphrodites right it was yeah i was
altering
alex jones not i'm not making fun of him
i think he's a national treasure he's
hilarious
but i was just you know that's a common
conspiracy theory that i could reference
from the right
but um yeah they literally put this plus
sign from inside the key handle
tiny detail from this um logo
and they're like look at how it matches
up next to a swastika
it didn't have any swastika shapes it
was literally a
plus sign a bold plus sign i i
yeah it there's that's how they were
trying to destroy this man
it's it's it's it's the
there's a valve the media acts as a
valve for politics
it's really interesting i it's kind of
like we have this weird system where
there's politics flowing around
kind of in in it no that doesn't make
sense but here's the point i'm trying to
make
when it comes to personal politics it
only flows in one direction to the right
so the left will kick you out they'll
ban you they'll attack you your opinions
are wrong and the right is just
recruiting everybody come on over we'll
take everybody we can get and we're
going to win
the raid was great to me yeah i mean so
the the easiest analogy is the left is
screaming and yelling while the right's
offering you a beer
yeah and even though they don't agree
with you they'll be like let's have a
conversation and i i point this out all
the time when i sat down with glenn beck
disagreeing on pro-life versus
pro-choice and we we laughed together
and we shook hands and we're like man
we got to figure out how to live
together we disagree and it was it was a
smile it was it was like this is great
we had a great conversation
we respected each other's opinions we
disagree with each other the life
doesn't do that
but there's something else happening
when it comes to the media the media
only flows to the left
so it's a weird thing where the where
the people flow right and the media
flows left
so here's what happens what would happen
if you came out right now and uh
no i'm not going to say it there are
several channels on youtube that have
been deleted outright
and some have been stripped from their
monetization for for saying things about
chronovirus
like doubting it or criticizing it gone
just like that
but of course if you come out and scream
hysteria and bloody murder you're fine
so what happens if you can't talk about
the other side of issues
it can only move left so it's almost
like a ratchet
it can only go one way you can't pull it
backwards so it keeps ratcheting
everything is ratcheting
more and more to the left and then
people because the left and the media is
going insane are being
shoved out and pushed to the right so i
got to say
you know in reference to bridget fedex's
article i wouldn't be surprised if trump
got a landslide either and these polls
may be wrong because they don't know
what they're talking about anymore
they i think their methodology is
probably broken all these pollsters
rasmussen was the only one who got it
right they were like i could say
i think they were the only one who got
it right on 2016. it was like they
predicted i think
two points and hillary got 1.7 or
something like that
i think they predicted 1.7 and she got
2.1 everyone else was like
hillary clinton's gonna win by three
they were the closest right now they're
saying trump's doing really really well
yeah so i wouldn't be surprised if trump
does win because of all of this stuff
because here i am forced into a corner i
have to go buy guns and then biden
threatens taking my guns away
and now i'm just like i'll tell you it's
a really it's a really interesting
thing the difference between never
having a gun and talking about gun
control and gun rights
and then owning a gun and having the
same kind of conversation because to
truly understand what these law mean
these laws mean you have to actually be
holding one and owning it it's yours
and then all of a sudden it's like hey
wait a minute i didn't do anything don't
take that
what did i i have this it's mine i'm a
good person don't take my gun from me
and now they are and so now i'm like
listen
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you